こんにちははじめ社長です上位42件の季節になってきましたね
受験生の皆さん勉強してますか
捨てないしろって言うべきはですね頑張っている受験生の皆さんにですね南東の紹介で
ございますみなさん at 食べてますか
なんとすごいんですよだから僕も受験生だったころですねカーズに納得はせられた時が
してなんか体調管理が大事なんですよ受験で何でも食べ物で何食べる方も結構大事だと
思うのであの的受験生のみんな
には納豆を食べていただきたい
もちろん受験生じゃない人も水で今回はこちらこちらの納豆体調管理におすすめです
すごいナット sq まるさんを見て下さいがんばれ受験生って書いてあるくらいです
そしてこの s 9番さんすごいところですねに1200種類以上もの納豆菌の中から
選ばれた傾向をサポートする優秀な納豆菌が使われているんですそんな様達な
どうなんですけども今日は納豆でそのまま食べることもあると思うんですけどもう何か
と組み合わせて食べること多いと思うんですよ
食べる今回はこちらあ最初からめちゃくちゃたくさん食べ物を準備したんでどの
食べ合わせが美味しいかはたまた
待っておれ
今日の動画お仕事があまりよくな表現を使っては会社が止まってしまう
構えろ言い方を考えを俺
ひとによって
おいしい顔ね迷うか
すべていきたいとおもいますグライガー廃墟機でさっそく食べて行きたいと思います
ちょめちゃ千原に入ってるんで多分余裕で食べると思う
全部は食べないですよ僕ナットめっちゃ好きなんですよ
家がダイエットように納豆だけ食べてる軸全く入れる
4素晴らしいあり
いいですねぇじゃなくてはうわさバサバサ masa 久場さをば層シールド乳酸菌が
減って語る
めっちゃ健康相談うーんはできましたもうこのままでよくねえ
てあげます
[音楽]
甘いが区別組み合わせじゃないしちゃったーって言ってまずはこちらご飯ですねご負担
となるとそれはを1円升頂きます
[音楽]
日本一おいしいこの目指させていたと思いますそして0がホシゴイ強化しますねご飯と
なると欲しい語で日本一美味しいですはいじゃあどんどん行きましょう次は五回とある
ような気もしますね餃子行ってみましょうか
餃子と納豆を食べてみますいただきます
[音楽]
バッハ
全然食えますねー
なんかあんまり字変換ないような意味する全然食べれます欲しいさん
カレーライス食べてみましょうこれもだっておく見たことがある者こういうレシピに
納豆カレーってことがあるくらいですからこれうまいでしょ
いただきます
[音楽]
バッチ米を私募ですやんまいな
うーんまなんか名前は聞いたことあるけど食べたことないですね納豆キムチ食べてみ
ましょうか
いただきます
うーんまあまあキムチのカーサ納豆のマイルドさで包み込んでいる感じだからみんな
混ぜて言ってるのかこれをし子です
続いてニック何言ってみましょうに配っとなった松田ことはあんまりないんだ
いただけます
[音楽]
あっ馬0納豆キムチキムチなったほどのインパクトはないけど美味しいですこれ納豆
マントが入ったら売れそうな気がしますね
星井さんですなおしたプレで厚木戦で言って皆さん
天井のなくともなかなか食べたことないって言っていただきます
[拍手]
[音楽]
んがああ
納豆のようならー
せんべいを上から
空けちゃっている
これは案件動画レイプ表現は必ず控えたいところでは考えられんなんでなんで言えば
いいんだ
何て言えばいいんだ
頭の
粘りとせんべいのバリばに感が打ち消し合ってていいなって思いました
星中です次行きましょう次はチーズと混ぜてみようと思いますなく当チームの中にが
飛んできるんよいただきます
[音楽]
複雑に店ですそれで牛豚までてみましょう
95となったも結構相性に気がするんですよいただきまー
[音楽]
うーんなんで効果も良い方はバッチ x-ねーならお肉のジューシーさは納豆で流し
キーだしている可能性
納豆いうのはなんでマイナーこれ星5で馬ね今と実はパン91んですかこれ
付いて判断がいきましょうアメリカと日本の巨大でしょう求めいただけます
[音楽]
うんまた来てしまったやはりはと米の融合はまだ難しいというのがもっと環境互いの
いいところとおっしゃっている
なんと表現したらいいんだ
なんか適当にた胸を言って本当日米は船長や1体です
ず焼きそば行ってみます意外といい企画
との相性はいただきます
意外とうまいなー茶屋つくばの面がそうめんみたいになってたねまりティガてて好きな
人たちそうです
3点美味しいです水で南行きましたなんと納豆の興味なさそう
聞かんですねーいただきます
おいしいおいしいおいしいけどなる後反応があっていただきましたね星さんです水で食
パンいきましょう
[音楽]
一花道くん続いてヨーグルト行ってみましょう用ベルトな凸と墓石連弾いただきます
素敵な食感なんだ早く
頭の狂言の必要なんか行けそうな気はしますね
好きだいた好きな気がします
でも2点で続いてチャー入ってみましょう
果たして脱党は中国と分かり合えるのか
いただきます
うわーめっちゃはずやなにこの馬だかなんとはないと成立しないオジとがある
いやーこれ一番がやチャーハンとなくとでしかなし得ないような味になっててるがクセ
になりそうですねこれ欲しい8です
美味しかったこれめちゃくちゃ a これナンバーワンかさては続いて活動でもなった
かーっ
ちょっと学校は聞いたことないんだいただきます
burn my は今江もトライのいいところの個ずつちょっとズルしてて美味しい
です4点
次行きましょうここで混ぜてみましょう
小山代表して知ると一緒に臨みますかいただきます
[拍手]
ああああああ
また来やがった今の組み合わせだ
おっ安元だった案件だった事ってるなぁえーっとえーっと
天井だ言っともっと言ってリーガー
どれも美味しいですねつぎ終売いただきます
うん食べ合わせ的には全然そんな悪い気はしないですねただもチャーハンのクリアて甘
すぎてなぁ
それを超えないとって感じですね4点です続いてピッチャーいきましょう
ピザクノップむくみやさん聞いたことないかいただきます
[音楽]
2点やサラダいきますあったとなっ
他方なるだろう
どういます
うんうんもらう場合全然食べやすいと
欲しいさんうどん同部はどうなるんだろうなぁマッタケ嘘をつかれていただきます
[音楽]
うんんあれよりうどん並
ナフトガスでマッチしてますね御天そば同じ感じの合う気がするんだよねいただきます
まあ年齢対象いいのかもしれ待ってですね欲しい語でおいしい
8体もう年齢やすげー自信があるいただきます
[音楽]
馬 a 0+たかなとが合うのかやる
甘いですこれこれは知られてない気がしますね fast とめっちゃいます5点です
ねが長くなった家がするウッドベース9トリュフ
グラターン作業用未知の領域が出来ましたいただきます
[音楽]
うまえええなーすげーなー皆さんも合うっておっしゃらなかったからすげークリーミー
で美味しかったです5点
なんではないかと
ここに違う
おにぎりいいと言っただけなんですけども先にご飯食べたけど一緒だと思うんですよね
あっバナナバナナと納豆の中だけ聞かんですねちょっと食べてみようと思います
いただきます
ガー
いやーキャッチャーしまう時ってねえと思ったらこのて部できあって
うん剣道などて3
梅雨悪いいいからしちまいそうになったです
はぁ
掃除機
[音楽]
あっもうアクターないでしょうスイッチ校に全員
これも未知の領域ですねポイントなんとってどうなんだろういただきます
[音楽]
入ってたぁー
させてください1点水でプリン食べてみましょう組のアノいかん気が組んでご覧
いただきます
[音楽]
ん
[拍手]
意外とアリだ
4点当たるこの流れだとちょっとアレだなと思ったんだけど意外と合いますねプリン
関してみるもんだな
だいふくもう知らんもうここはだけど俺は知らんです聞いてあげます
あら意外とおいしいは意外と嬉しいでなんかあつってめっちゃくちゃ
マッチと寄与する4点です甘いファンも全然食えるこれ
薄い大福がめちゃくちゃいいですねカステラもう試したことないなぁ
相続食べようと思った人がいるかどうかを知りたいですいただけます
[音楽]
ban
鎌滝上がっちゃう
なんだよこれ
じゃあのスポンジに吸い付いてくるじゃねーから
マーケットが持つて付け落ち
っていうけど正直な感想もみんなに伝え税
大変です欲しい地たイナ go これまだ特殊隊特殊の組み合わせですねいただきます
んあ意外と悪くはないけど
ホセにアボカドアップガードと納豆なんても聞いたこともないよ
ておきます
をその
あれよりのあり売りのなしにてるみかんこれこれキューブが正しいけど小学校ん時やっ
たんだよな
なんか駄目だった気がします僕の
記憶によると
[音楽]
案の定でも酸っぱいの納豆ちょっと呼び説明いただきます
はぁ
ん
ふーん
でも酸っぱいんですけどなんかなっとじゃあしない
いっぱい納豆でした
[音楽]
さてんです相手にで食べ物げあ人とに終わったんですけども
国家だと超メディアとの組み合わせ見ていきますの5万がー
できます
パウマっ久保利夫んですまあ
飛びの合うなみそ
n
[音楽]
う
ひとによってはと思います香水っ
初めて初
5番なんかにそうな気がするんだよなぁ
[音楽]
5死にマヨネーズや意外とありそうで行ったことない組み合わせですよね
星にこんなチーズチーズはたぶん大丈夫そう
[音楽]
梅田ない前に出てほしいよ美味しいイチゴジャムんうん
道付ければイチゴジャムとなんでためのことないをいただきます
[音楽]
理化学で里欲しいよーなんか意外と舌アウトっぽくすればいいんだろうオリーブオイ
オリーブオイル缶いただきます
あんまり変化はありませんお子さん和風ドレッシング
[音楽]
馬柄が増えてしまいますね波信号です甘い4年前ごまドレッシングなどれシーン系と
すごい相性が良い気がしております
いただきます
[音楽]
馬柄は星子ドレッシング西9似合うな
この流れで行くと多分シーザードレッシング回るのではないでしょうか
やります
うまえこっちもドレッシングマナー留作最初ですねあずき
なんかねぼく今回おったんすけどあまり頃と結構相性いい t やすいですよ
いただきます
[音楽]
いい
もう馬へ何か甘い納豆ができますね
腰よやはり星5ですね甘い前なんか売っちゃ美味しいです次な組み合わせが美味しい
もんだな
水飴うまっ長はまあそうこんな病とあー歌手とか分からんですよねうーん
納豆といっしょ取るいただきます
[音楽]
ん
意外と美味しい
仕様デジャヴなと甘いのかはいっしょいいですね
では最後の激辛ソースです納豆はマイルドな染めだったら消してくれるでしょうきっと
美味しいこと間違いなしですねいただきます
[音楽]
バーン
あ今は辛い腰に佩いと夕食
メコンでこちらのすごいなあと s 級まあるさんでいろんな組み合わせる食べてみ
ました
個人的に一番おいしかったのはチャーハンですねチャーのめちゃくちゃ美味しかったで
ここでもう一度たくさんあったんでぜひ皆さんいろんな組み合わせでなんと食べてみて
ください
だけで実現の聞けて体調本当に崩しちゃダメなんですよ
体調は一番大事と言っても過言ではありません取り上げる受験生のみんな
このすごいなと一級マルちゃんと僕は今回教えた組み合わせ
受験を乗り越えようすごいなと sq まるさんの詳細は動画の概要欄にありますので
是非皆さんチェックしてみてください
じゃあな
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ